Донеччина — це terra incognita
[з латині — невідома земля] для туристів.
Ніхто не може сказати, що вони її знають.
Все, що вони знають, — це стереотипне.
Коли ти навчишся приймати гостей,
от тоді ти зможеш усе.
Як я можу міркувати або хтось розповідати
про Донеччину, коли я ніколи тут не була?
Більшість своєї роботи я вже
спрямувала на внутрішній туризм.
У нас був такий клуб мандрівників,
ми приймали в Донецьку і в Донецькій області
гостей з інших регіонів,
і своїх возили по області,
а на новорічні та травневі свята возили Україною.
Вони чекали завжди чогось новенького,
і я вимушена була їздити областю,
по таких селах, як Крива Лука,
та шукала щось цікаве.
Бо містянам, донецьким,
мільйонному місту було цікаво.
Просувати якусь українську культуру у Львові
чи Києві мені здається легше, ніж тут.
І якщо українське тут шукати і відшукувати:
етнографію, культуру і генетичні риси,
тут їх можна побачити навіть виразніше,
ніж в регіоні, де це природніше.
Тому що їх мало, але вони виразніші.
Якби ви подивилися на нашу туристичну мапу,
яку ми зробили, там є зовсім не туристичні речі.
Там є шар цілий присвячений зниклій спадщині.
Ми ще довго думали як його позначити,
ми його привидами позначили.
Тобто воно навіть не індетифікується зараз,
що тут колись було якесь поселення.
Але ми нанесли на мапу,
нехай це нетуристичні речі,
але вони дуже важливі для того,
щоб хоча б зберігати пам'ятку про те, що жили тут люди.
Велосипед  — це незалежність, автономність,
рух, здоров'я та гарний настрій.
У нас навіть люди переважно за містом багато куди їздять.
Тому велосипед гарна річ, яка може цьому допомогти.
Ніхто не знає за Донеччину взагалі нічого.
Людина, яка тут ніколи не була,
не знає що тут насправді.
А коли ми показуємо фотографії,
у людини йде розрив шаблону.
— Люди їздять містами та купують як їх?
— Туристична марка.
Так, туристична марка, і вони їх збирали.
Ми робимо таке саме посвідчення, але на квест.
Наприклад: в Кривій Луці
треба виконати сім завдань, щоб тобі зарахували,
то треба поїхати туди сфотографуватись,
знайти якесь місце,
і ти  показуєш виконані завдання
і тобі роблять відмітку (штамп).
Тоді тобі цей квест зараховано,
ти пройшов цей етап.
Що ви робите? Яка місія? Розказати та показати.
Моя яка ? Розказати показати.
Хтось ще з іншого боку теж,
тому хотілось об'єднати зусилля,
бо тоді ми можемо на виході щось конкретне отримати.
Саме так, мені теж дуже хотілося б.
В 2014 році коли почались перші події,
між собою люди спілкувалися та питали:
«А ти за кого? За Україну чи Росію?»
Якщо чесно, то взагалі не розуміла питання,
за кого я можу бути, якщо живу в цій країні!?
Ну і досі такі запитання для мене такі очевидні.
То був час коли дуже хотілось сховатись
та десь пересидіти, нікого не бачити, не чути.
Багато років до того я приїжджаласюди відпочивати,
і я тут відчуваю дуже спокійно та затишно.
Підсвідомо думала, що повернемося,
але і робити треба щось.
І от почалася міжнародна технічна допомога,
почала в новинах бачити інформацію
про гранти, і подумала чому б ні?
Гради [реактивна система залпового вогню]
ось тут стояли у нас.
Я маму спустила, їй було 90 років, вона війну пройшла.
Тільки-но спустила в підвал,
ось тут прямо БТР летить на всій швидкості.
Зіпсували мені город. Але мама каже,
слава Богу, що ми живі залишилися.
З 2014 року українська частина наших міст зрозуміла,
що ми не далеко одне від одного і треба єднатися.
Ми вже дізналися  [англійською] хто є хто.
Дізналися тих людей, які так само люблять Україну.
Всі по-різному подивилися на такі
вже звичні речі як: українську мову,
на свята зовсім інше ставлення тепер,
до Дня Незалежності, до Дня Конституції теж,
до державних символів, до мови
та й до самого життя — більше цінувати почали.
Леонід Миколайович фотограф у нас.
Почалося все з того, що я почала
його запрошувати як фотографа.
— Добрий день.
— І перші роки ми разом.
Село повинно бути таким класним, чистим.
Тому я тут і роблю, щоб було класно.
Сільське господарство у мене було тільки в дитинстві,
коли я їздив до бабусі у Вінницьку область.
Трошки несподівана для мене переорієнтація,
бо я займався та викладав в Інституті Міліції
криміналістику, судові експертизи.
В університеті викладав фотопрактику журналістів.
Мав свою фотошколу в Донецьку, але воно все пішло,
переналаштувався і все нормально.
Кажуть після бойових дій страшно,
ні — нам не страшно вже.
Може, хтось там подивиться з іншого регіону України
та подумає, що тут безглузді люди живуть.
Який Донбас? Який внутрішній туризм?
Але нам не здається це дуже смішно.
Насправді робимо те, що можемо, що маємо робити.
Мій внесок — розвиваємось,
об'єднуючи людей навколо місцевої спадщини.
Я ж об'їздив всю Донецьку область,
це така ж гарна область як і інші.
Це не тільки заводи й терикони [відвали, штучний насип порід].
Тут дуже багато таких цікавих місць.
Це була ділянка наших друзів.
Почалась війна, ми приїхали сюди і тут жили.
Вони побачили, що ми нічого
не можемо робити, бо чужа земля.
І подарували всю цю землю, сказали:
все, займайтеся, це вже ваше.
І ми почали вже щось робити.
Там у нас наметовий кемпінг.
Це тільки початок, плануємо
змінити намети на дерев'яні будинки.
Цього року почнемо. От там ми викосили траву,
підготовлювати місце для басейну,
щоб відпочивальники могли не тільки
йти на річку, хоч тут і річка не далеко,
але комфортніше, коли тут на кемпінгу.
Спека — пішов, занурився.
Ця вся частина буде під сосни,
щоб збирати тут гриби,
щоб не ходити до лісу, а можна було
піти в кінець городу та назбирати грибів.
Нарвати з дітьми ягід та поїсти.
Мені кажуть, якщо запустиш людей,
то вони тут все у тебе обірвуть та обламають.
Тому мені хотілось, щоб наші люди себе
відчували більш по-європейськи у всьому.
Ідея клубу виникла після 2015 року.
Нас усе спонукало до єднання.
Велоклуб — це і є частина громади, активна її частина,
бо коли люди щось вирішують і роблять разом — це актив.
Тому це один з локомотивів розвитку громади
та громадської спільноти.
Є в нас бажання, як ми обговорювали
минулого року, цього року може впровадимо.
Це розробка туристичних веломаршрутів,
маркування велолокацій на цих маршрутах.
Долучити маємо багато людей, є в нас ще маленькі діти,
молоде покоління, яке з радістю доєднається.
От якраз це питання розвитку велоінфраструктури.
Коли буде безпечно,
тоді більше людей пересяде на велосипед.
Учасники клубу планують якісь виїзди,
можливо, з ночівлею.
От саме по нашому регіону,
по цікавих місцях, як-от Крива Лука.
У такий спосіб відпочиваємо та
робимо наш регіон популярнішим, відомішим.
Це дуже красивий край.
Ми тут народилися, виросли і
їхати звідси поки що не плануємо.
Взагалі-то тут цікаві люди, цікаві місця,
і тут можна робити як кажуть,
Захід України тут так само,
але все воно впочатковому стані.
Треба його, як ту рослину,
поливати та вона виросте та буде гарною.
Ми показуємо, які красиві місця є у нас на Сході.
На Заході теж безліч красивих місць,
і в Центрі вони є, і на Півдні теж.
Насправді ми є унікальною країною
і це потрібно цінувати, знати та подорожувати.
Ці два кадри були зроблені в один день.
Різниця три хвилини.
Сфотографував одну сторону,
розвернувся сфотографував іншу сторону.
Ось таке небо було цікаве.
Це рано-вранці, тут тумани.
Ну, є що познімати, наше село.
Використовуємо термін «екотуризм».
Може, я себе заспокоюю, що для екотуризму
шикарна інфраструктура не має значення. Може, помиляюся.
На кілька днів ми вже можемо зайняти людину.
В наметовому кемпінгу, розказати,
показати, приділити увагу, нагодувати.
Мені здається, що тут людина може побути
з природою на самоті, відчути її.
Село живе!
Хочеться жити в цьому селі і ніде не виїжджати.
Хто хоче — долучається, хто не хоче — відпочиває.
Я сподіваюсь, що моя робота змінює на краще.
Сподіваюсь, що такий наш рух вперед
і до сильної України,
безумовної любові до України,
приєднає згодом і тих, хто зараз не сприймає.
Я вже вирішив, що звідси я вже нікуди не поїду.
Буду займатися, доводити це місце до нормального стану,
щоб було цікаво.
Це наше, це все наше.
Коли людина буде розуміти, що все,
що навколо, це його.
Та буде ставитися як до свого, то буде нормально.
Це треба все розбудовувати, розвивати.
Бо росте Донеччина і росте Україна.
Як для самих українців,
так і для інших гостей з інших країн.
По одному переб'ють швидко.
Тому треба єднатися і робити, щоб Україна тут була.